Lance Reddick may be gone but the
legendary actor will never be forgotten
the casts of John Wick 4 took time
during the premiere of the film to pay
tribute to their departed friend
Lance Reddick who played the Continental
Hotel slick and Savvy concierge Sharon
died on March 17th 2023 age 60. radic
appeared in all four John Wick films and
they're slated to appear in the upcoming
Anna di Amos LED franchise spin-off
ballerina variety reports that attendees
of the Los Angeles premiere of John Wick
4 were asked to wear a blue ribbon pin
upon entering the TCL Chinese Theater
blue was reddick's favorite color all of
the events attendees including lead star
Keanu Reeves and directed Chad
stachelski had their snaps taken with a
simple but beautiful tribute while
speaking with star Lawrence Fishburne
Entertainment Tonight noted that
reddick's character poster was the first
one to greet attendees at the chapter 4
premiere in general the atmosphere of
the premiere was celebratory but solemn
Fishburne told ET at the premiere we
lost our brother we lost our brother
Reeves also praise the late actor joined
the red carpet describing Reddick as a
people person and special artists while
speaking with variety it's just really
something special every time he stepped
on set to watch the passion he had for
his work it's really easy to work with
him as Reeves succinctly put it while
talking to deadline
the love and respect for Reddick and his
John Wick character continued inside the
screening room as well and as always
it is a pleasure having you with us
again
Mr weak before Keanu Reeves and director
Chad stachowski took to the stage to
introduce the film The Hollywood
Reporter noted that president of the
Lionsgate Motion Picture group Joe Drake
a paid tribute to Lance Reddick Drake
said to Applause it would be impossible
to not acknowledge how profoundly sad we
are by the loss of Lance Reddick the
executive that acknowledged how
impactful the loss of Relic was in honor
of the late actor Drake implored those
in the auditorium to celebrate the actor
with Applause tonight what I would like
to do however is to ask you to make a
loud honoring grateful Applause for a
man who was an absolutely extraordinary
human being extraordinary actor and a
big part of this franchise Reddick
received a standing ovation from those
in the cinema Hall John Wick chapter 4
screened after an introduction by both
Keanu Reeves and Chad stahelski Variety
in attendance at the premiere noted that
Lance reddick's first appearance in the
film received considerable Applause from
viewers shortly after the film's
premiere deadline confirm that John Wick
chapter 4 was dedicated in reddick's
memory stahlski told variety I just got
to be happy and be proud of the fact
that I got to spend so much time with
him we're going to miss him while
Reddick was widely celebrated for his
decade-long stint in John Wick the actor
is also a membered for a starring role
in The Wire after his death was
confirmed the wire crater David Simon
took to social media to praise the actor
tweeting consummate professional devoted
collaborator lovely and gentleman loyal
friend in addition to his roles on the
big and small screen Redick was an
integral part of Bungie's Destiny video
game where he played Commander Zavala
the hours following his passing
thousands of Destiny players took to
zavala's in-game location to pay tribute
to the actor the act of kindness and
support was later commended in an
official statement by Lance reddick's
wife Stephanie the latest John Wick film
is reddick's first posthumous role the
actor Will next be seen in Hulu's remake
of White Men Can't Jump and or headline
Disney Plus's adaptation of Percy
Jackson and the Olympians as Zeus
[Music]